hello
and thank you for joining us for today's
presentation
part of our agilent cell analysis global
conference
my name is yama abbasi and i'm the vice
president of business development at
acea biosciences which is now
part of agilent technologies and i'll be
your host
for this presentation before i introduce
our speaker for today
allow me to share a bit about agilent
our products
and our products for cell analysis
agilent as a leader
in life sciences is very focused on
enabling our customers to gain the
insights they seek
a rapidly growing cell analysis
portfolio
enables deeper more reliable insights
across a variety of cell analysis
applications
where investigators and drug developers
seek to understand
dynamic cellular environments and
interactions
this is critically important in
the large and growing immune oncology
and immunotherapy
fields for example discovering
safe potent and persistent immune cell
products
requires more comprehensive
understanding of cancer biology
and immune cell function our
presentation today
our presentations today will speak
specifically to our solutions and how
they are being
employed in that context our speaker
dr juan miguel sanchez nieto
studied biotechnology at francisco de
vittoria
university in madrid spain he moved to
london in 2010 where he did his masters
in molecular medicine
at university college london juan miguel
continued his scientific career
at imperial college london where he
completed a phd
in developmental and stem cell biology
his research was focused on
understanding the differential
sensitivity to cell death
observed at the onset of embryonic stem
cell
differentiation he joined sal and gene
therapy catapult industrialization team
in 2017
as an analytical developmental scientist
juan miguel has been involved in the
experimental design
and execution of multiple projects
related to the development of
novel analytics for viral vector
stem cell and somatic cell therapies he
has been
leading selling gene therapy catapults
efforts in the development
and qualification of in vitro potency
assays
for tcr and car t cell based
immunotherapies
i had the pleasure of meeting juan
miguel last year at catapults facilities
in london
which was a very impressive facility
with some
spectacular views of uh london
um before i hand over to juan miguel
a couple of housekeeping notes uh there
will be question and answer
period immediately following the talk
and to help us get as many questions as
possible
we encourage you to type in your
questions
during the presentation and with that i
will pass it on to
juan miguel thank you
hello everyone and thank you very much
jama for your kind introduction
and also thank you to the teams adiden
and lapreus for
giving me the chance of presenting at
this global event today
um also i would like to thank you for
attending this
session where i will try to share with
you some of the results that we obtain
trying to develop an impedance based
asset to evaluate the potency of
immunotherapy
products but
before going into the results i would
like also to take this opportunity
to introduce our organization the
serendium therapy catapult we are part
of a world-leading network of technology
and innovation centers that are
strategically located around the united
kingdom
we were established by innovate uk as a
non-for-profit independence center
back in 2012 and it is our vision for
the uk to be
a global leader in the development
delivery
and commercialization of cell and
genotherapies
and we can do this by supporting
businesses
to start grow and confidently
confidently develop advanced therapies
and try to get into the patients as
rapidly and effectively as possible
we can support these businesses through
our development center
that is based in central london here we
have a fantastic professional team
that can support analytical
characterization activities
uh process development and scaling up
using different types of bioreactors
we have a dedicated viral vector team
and also
a stem cell expansion and
differentiation platform
in addition we are developing an
integration and collaboration center
where we will be able to work directly
with our collaborators
we also have a manufacturing center
located in stevenage
here we have 12 segregated large clean
rooms
that a leading 17 therapy companies can
use to start a manufacturing products to
support their clinical trials
or vibrate before commercialization
in addition we can support you with uh
different areas such as regulatory
affairs health economics or
clinical support but if you have any
other questions please don't hesitate to
contact
us or you can visit our website for
further information
after that brief introduction of our
organization
now we can move on with the rest of the
presentations
on how we have developed potency assets
for immunotherapies
using the impedance platform
so with this slide i would like to
highlight what is the current procedure
of manufacturing of a t-cell products
the process starts when we receive the
patient material into the manufacturing
facility
and here it undergoes several steps such
as washing
selection of the material and then we
need to activate the cells
to start inducing cell proliferation
a few days after we use viral vector to
be able to
insert our transient of interest into
the patient material
and then this is followed up by an
expansion period of
1 to 10 days that will allow cell
preparation to generate enough material
for the patient the last step consists
on
washing and concentrating the material
and resuspending it into the final
formulation
however before the product is released
from the manufacturing facility
it must pass some quality control and
release criteria
where we need to verify the identity
of the product by characterizing the
type of cells that we can find on it
what is the appearance what are the
level of impurities so in this case that
could be
the percentage of non-cd3 positive cells
we also have to ensure that the product
is safe
so in this case showing that it's
completely sterile
or that the levels of mycoplasma or
endotoxins
are within the acceptance criteria and
also we need to evaluate the potency of
the product
in this case we can look at different
parameters such as the circadian
activity
or cytokine stimulation when the
t-cells the engineer cells recognize
their target cells
but one of the important challenges that
the industry faces
nowadays is to try to reduce this
manufacturing process
and also the steps between quality
control release and the time that it
needs to go
to the patient
so the current methods that people
normally use to evaluate
this potency are based on the chromium
release assay
this assay is the golden standard in the
literature
and for those of you who are not very
familiar with it there is a
diagram on the right hand side of the
image that try to explain how it works
the first step would be to incubate our
target cells with a radioactive compound
which is chromium 51
after we have incubated our target cells
with these radioactive reagents
we will culture them with the effector
cells
or the engineered user when the
engineers t-cell recognizes the target
cell
it will induce its cell death and the
chromium 51 will be released to the
supernatant
and then we can measure the amount of
economy 51 released
as a way of measuring the potency of the
product
however the use of this type of asset
has several limitations
one of them is time longing incubation
times can lead
to chromium 51 and specific leakage
and that can make some a little bit
complicated interpretation of our
results
another aspect would be the safety one
so we will have to have
a dedicated specific area to be able to
handle radioactive materials
and another limitation would be cell
requirements
this type of assay needs to use normally
high effective to target ratios and so
that means that we will need to use many
more
effector cells to be able to serve a
healing effect on the target cells
and if these ratios are very high then
we will lose the
physiological relevance of the assay
another important aspect is that when we
are developing
these quality control release assays
the idea is to try to use as little as
possible of the patient's material
so then the patient can receive as much
as possible of the
finalized products so over the years
there has been some developments
trying to find alternatives to these
chromium 51 release assay
for example we could use a kit that is
called
cytotox 96 in this case it measures
the release of a cytosolic enzyme which
is structured the heterogeneous
through absorbance there are
other keys such as the cell tighter glow
in this case
it measures atp through luminescence
or we could monitor a other
release of different dyes that are not
already active in this case
an example would be calcium am or
the tda release as well and we can also
use other technologies such as flow
cytometry where we can monitor
cell death or also cytokine release
or other technologies such as luminex
fertilizer again to measure cytokine
release
however all these different technologies
requires
a pre-labeling either the effector or
the target cells
to be able to identify the kidney ratios
or another disadvantage is that
we are not able to obtain any
information about the
kinetics or the dynamics of the killings
so is the operator the person that needs
to determine
which is the optimal time point to be
able to observe
these killing effects
so one potential alternative to be able
to
overcome some of these limitations is to
use an impedance-based
potency assay this platform is a
real-time cell analysis system
that is non-invasive for the cells and
is based on electrical impedance so it's
just a small electrical pulse
that we go through the cells but it
doesn't affect their identity
or their viability it's a label-free
assay
so we don't need to label either the
effector or the target cells
saving time and reagents
the platform that we have at our
organization
offers high throughput because we can
put up to 696 volt plates that
give us the possibility of testing many
different conditions at the same time
and it's also very flexible because each
of the 964 plates
is independent from each other so
different operators can start
different experiments at the time of the
convenience
however it has also some limitations and
we need to optimize
the process for each a specific target
cell line
that we are using so
how did we decide to use this platform
in our organization to evaluate the
potency
of engineering cells we followed two
different strategies
the first one was to try to measure the
potency for a t-cell
receptor-based therapy or a tcr-based
therapy
and in this case we evaluated the use of
either
non-adherent target cells or adeline
target cells
and the second strategy was to try to
evaluate the potency
for a chimeric antidote receptor or
cardi
cell base therapy and in this case we
only used having target sense
but how does the impedance potential say
work so for those of you who are not
very familiar with the instrument
you have a picture of it on the left
hand side of the
slide so we have the laptop with the
software and then on the right hand side
you can see
um the part of the unit that has
the platforms for the 696 volt plates
and on the bottom you can see
how the special plates that we need to
use for this instrument
that are called e-plates look like
hopefully you can appreciate that they
are coated with
gold microelectrodes that they are going
to be used to measure the electrical
impedance
so for the acid to be able to work we
need to have a
conductive solution such as the cell
culture medium
and then once we apply a small
electrical current
the electrons will be able to flow from
a one electrode to the other and
just in the presence of medium the
electrons can flow freely so there is
nothing that
is going to block the the flow
and that is interpreted as a zero cell
index
uh cell index are the arbitrary units
that we use to monitor
impedance once we add our target cells
the cells will start to attach and once
they attach
they will block or imply or impede this
electron flow and that is translated as
an increase
of the cell index the more sense
attached
the higher the cylinders would be and
then once we have
a maximum attachment the signal will
reach a plateau
and that is a specific time point that
we are looking to be able to add
our effector cells once we add our
effector cells
they will recognize the target cells
they will kill them
and these target cells will die
detach from the blade and that killing
effect is
translated as a decrease on the cell
index
and that's how we can monitor in real
time the
potency of our t-cells
so let's move on and see what are the
steps that we follow trying to develop
this assay for a tcr
based product so
before just starting to explain
our results let me just try to introduce
a little bit how the tcl mediated
killing occurs
for the teacher to be able to recognize
and kill the
target cell we will need two different
signals
the first signal is given by the
interaction of the t-cell receptor or
tcr
and the major histocompatibility complex
one
mhc-1 loaded with the antigen of
interest
so this recognition is the first primary
signal however this is not enough for
the t-cell
to kill the cancer cell we need a
secondary signal that is given
by a different core receptors
in this case this is represented by cd28
and 41bb
but there are many others so depending
on the
expression of the receptors and the
interactions that they get
the response of the t cell will be
modulated so once the t cell receives
these two signals so the tcr with the
mhc
loaded with the antenna of interest and
the core receptors
the downstream signal in cascades will
induce changes
in cell metabolism cell proliferation
and cytokine signation
that will ultimately lead to the
targeting and healing of the cancer cell
so what are the steps that we follow to
develop our assay
the first step was to select a suitable
target cell line
and in this case we chose
three different adeline cells cell line
1 and cell line 3 were melanoma cancer
cells
and in the literature it was published
that they expressed our antigen of
interest
selling number two it was an ovarian
cancer cell line and in the literature
it was reported that it does not express
our antigen of interest so we could use
cell m1 and cell m3 as positive controls
for the assay
and send the number to as a negative
control in addition for some of
our quality control experiments we use a
control cell line that was used
previously in the literature
then the next step was to evaluate the
optimal seeding density
to perform the cubing assay and
we also needed to verify that the cells
express
the mhsc class 1 and for that we use an
hla a2 antibody
and after these steps were optimized we
proceeded to perform the assay
qualification
the things that we evaluated were the
instrument linearity so in this case we
wanted to find out if there was a direct
correlation
between the number of cells that visited
and the cell index
then we also wanted to see if there was
also a correlation between the
psychological potential of our cells
and the same index and for that we used
two different parameters
the first one was the killing time 50
which is the amount of time that we need
to be able to reduce the normalized
index from 1 to 0.5 so basically to
reduce it by half
and then the second parameter was the
same index i
at the specific time points that this
was determined by the operators
and the last parameter that was
evaluated was precision so
the scatter of the spread of the results
with different measurements performed by
one single operator
and how it compared to the measurements
taken by
a second operator
so uh here are the results of the
evaluation of the optimal seed intensity
for each of the cell lines in this case
we used three different densities 12
500 that is in color blue 25
000 in red and 50 000 cells per well in
green
and a as you can see at the beginning of
the
essay there seems to be a correlation
between
cell index and number of cells so the
more number of cells that we put the
higher the cell index
would be and we managed to get
cell index around one which is the value
that we were looking for
as recommended by the manufacturer to be
able to perform this type of assays
with the lower cell density that we
tested and towards the end of the assay
we were not able to distinguish any
differences
between 25 000 cells or 50 000 cells
so it's likely that at this point the
cells were
over confluent on the well
in addition to this we also tested if we
could improve
cell attachment and addition by um
recoating the wells with fibronectin and
as you can see we managed to improve
um the speed of attachment and the
strength of attachment
because the cell index increased
dramatically when we pre-coated the
wells
with fibronectin you can clearly see
that if you look
at the blue line which is the lower cell
density that we tested
uh just pretty much a little bit after
seeding
the cell index almost reaches a value of
two whereas in the world that was not
with hyperconnecting we were not even
reaching
a cell index one
the second cell line cell line number
two gave us
a completely different profile of cell
index so that's why it's critical to
optimize
the sensing intensities for each of the
target segments that you are going to
use
during your experiments as you can see
these cells
attach in a stronger way
as because the cell index reaches values
of around 7
with the lower cell density and which
again
is in the blue color twenty five
thousand cells
um attached really really fast and
managed to
we managed to save this plateau around
250 minutes after sealing the cells
and something that was quite interesting
was to see that in the higher cell
density 50 000 cells per well
we saw a very strong attachment at the
beginning but as you can see over time
the cell index decreases
and we believe what happens is that the
cells were overconfluent
at the time of seeding and then there
was not enough nutrients in the medium
and the cells started to die
and that was translated in a decrease of
cell index
the use of a connecting again improved
the cell attachment
as you can see with the lower cell
density in blue
the cell index reaches higher values
compared to the ones
in the absence of fibronectin and the
signal is more stable
but we still observe the same effect
with the
higher cell density 50 000 cells we can
see the decrease of cell index over time
due to the overconfidency
and surprisingly with our third cell
line
we didn't reach a cell index one which
is the value that we were looking for
if any of the cell densities that we
tested in the absence of fibronectin
however when we coated the wells with
these
recombinant protein we managed to
improve the
attachment and addition of these cells
dramatically
and with the lower cell concentration we
managed to get
to set index 1 as we were expecting
um the next thing that we did was to
evaluate the expression
of the mhcc class 1 complex
which if you guys you remember from the
previous slides
is the is required for the dcr mediated
and in this publication what they did
was to
pause or to incubate
with increasing concentrations of
peptide target cells
and they saw that this increased the
expression levels of the
mhsc class 1 and they measure this using
an hla2 antibody
so we wanted to follow the same strategy
to see if by
pulsing the cells with our antigen or
peptide of interest
we could increase the expression levels
of the image c class 1
and therefore trying to increase the
chances of being able to observe
a more clear healing effect using the
appearance platform
so then what we did was try to replicate
what they did in the
in that application so for that we
incubated ourselves with our peptide of
interest
and we managed to replicate the results
so using
their control cell line we observed an
increase in the expression levels of hla
a2
when ours when the cells were paused
with the antigen of interest
however this effect was not observed in
any of our variant cell lines
cell number three though show very high
expressions of hli a2
a segment number one little expression
of a hlaa2
and we were not able to detect the
expression of this protein in
in cell line number two
but it was not very relevant at this
point because that cell line is the one
that we were using
or planning to use as a negative control
given that it was reported in the
researcher that didn't express
our antigen of interest
the next type of experiment that we did
was to see if there was a negative
effect
on the cell index when we culture
the cell line number one and cell number
three
in the presence of non-transient cells
so in here what we wanted to evaluate
was if the non-transducers had a
negative impact
on on the readout of the impedance assay
in the presence of the target cells and
you can see that there was a slight
reduction
in the cell index for both of the cell
lines
but we didn't see a dramatic decrease
and the the normalized index never went
underneath
a one which is the if it goes underneath
one then it would be a sign
of uh circadian so we decided to move
forward with segment number three
uh to keep developing the potency assay
as with the lower cell density
we managed to get ice index of around
one
uh it was a cell line that show highest
expression levels of hla
a2 among the cell lines that we tested
and it had a relatively more constant
cell index over time
compared to the other cell lines showing
a little bit less of non-specific
killing
so the first thing that we did was to
try to evaluate the instruments in
linearity so this is trying to see if
there is a correlation between the
number of cells that we plated and the
cell index values
so for that what we did was to see
different cell concentrations
with an increased constant cell number
and then we evaluated the cell index in
all the values that are in between the
black dotted lines
so here you have the results of the
first
linearity experiment and you can see
that the
r squared value the coefficient of
correlation is very
good it's over 0.97
indicating that there is actually a
direct correlation between the number of
cells that we have plated
and digital index
however on the second experiment even
though the
score value is still very good again
over 0.97 you can see
that the cell index values were slightly
higher compared to the first experiment
and in the third replica we obtain
values that were closer
to experiment number one in
this slide just wants to highlight the
sensitivity of this platform of the
impedance based assay to detect
different cell densities once we plate
them on
on the e blades and how important
is to be consistent uh throughout
all all of the process from detaching
the cells
until they are seated on on the
impedance plates so this requires
different manipulation steps such as
detaching the cells from the vessel they
were in
performing cell counts spinning the
cells down and then respecting in the
desired concentration
as an example if the cell dissociation
was not great
and then we have a small cell glands
then these clamps will affect the
overall circumstance results
and we will not be seeing the amount of
cells
that we thought we were going to have
so once we have shown that we can
establish a linear correlation between
number of cells
plated and cell index then we
decided to move on and actually plan the
experiments to be able to evaluate the
psychologies
and see if there is a direct correlation
between cytolysis and scientists
so for that the approach that we took
was to fix
a an effective to target ratio in this
case was a two to one
and effective to target ratio if you
remember
the optimal signal density that we
decided to use was 3500 cells
and therefore we will need a total of 25
000
t cells for this type of experiments
and then we decided to mix transduced
or basically killer cells with
non-transduced cells
in different proportions to see if we
can find a correlation between the
cytolytic potential
and the cell index and in order to be
able to measure this correlation we
evaluated two different parameters the
first one
was the killing 1050 which is
represented by the red of that line
and the killing time 50 is the amount of
time that we need
to reduce the normalized index from
a1 to 0.5 and
the second parameter that we evaluated
was a decimal index or the normalized
index
at a specific time point so
for this type of assay what we do is to
normalize the cell index to the
point uh where we are our t cells
so in this case is on the y axis at the
time zero so when we add the t cells
that is the normalization point
uh and as you can see on the graphs when
we don't have any transduced material
which is the
top like light orange color um
there is no killing effect as the
normalized cell index keeps over one
when we add some transducer cells when
we have five percent intensive cells
which is the black line
there is some reduction on the cell
index compared to the previous condition
but still we don't see any active
killing as this normal cell index keeps
over one only when we start to have more
transience material at 20
40 is when we start observing a more
dramatic
healing effect and
it's it is more apparent with the large
amount of
celsius material plastic cells so as you
can see on the blue color when we have
only transient cells
the cylinder occurs very very fast and
we managed to
almost go to normalized cell intake hero
so that would mean almost
killing all the target cells that were
plated
so in these graphs you have the results
of the two different parameters the
killing 950
and the cell index in this case a time
420 minutes
and we found an exponential correlation
for
experiments two and three and not for
experiment one in this case
as you can see in experiment one number
one they pretty much have the same
killing 1050 values independently of the
amount of transit material
but for experiments number two and
number three we observed
a reduction in the kirin 1050
with increasing concentrations of
transient cells
and when we look at the graph on the
right hand side
the cell index at a specific time point
we can observe
that the more transduced material that
we have
the lower is the value of the normalized
cell index
indicating higher healing
human ratios
and again we also managed to serve an
exponential correlation
for this analysis the next thing that we
did was to try to
prove the specificity of the product and
for this we took two different
approaches we compared first
what are the differences between culture
in our target cells in the presence of
transduced
or non-transitive cells and this was
performed by two different operators
and you can see that we can only observe
a
dramatic active killing when we use
transduced cells
that is the the red line on the grass
and this effect is not observed in the
presence of control diesels
and the other experiment that we did
to prove the specificity was to use the
cell number two that we had
so if you remember this cell line is the
one that does not express
our antigen of interest so in theory
they are not susceptible
to be recognized uh by our t-cells
however in here we cannot distinguish if
we didn't detect the killing
due to the absence of our antigen of
interest
or because the cells don't express the
mhsc
class one and because if you remember we
were not able to detect this
with the antibody that we used but as
you can see in the graphs
when we use the transduced t cells we
were not able to observe
any killing
and the last parameter that we tested
was the intermediate precision
and repeatability so in this case two
different operators
performed experiments with transducers
and what we did was to see
how was the spread of the different
repeats that they performed
um evaluating the healing time 50.
so as you can see the three replicates
for operator number one are very close
to each other and the
repeats that operator number two perform
are also very good and there were no
significant differences
in the values that each operator
obtained
when evaluating the killing by 50.
when we plotted all all the different
experiments together
we observed that we managed to reduce
the normal excel index
from 1 to 0.5 in about
2 hours only with a standard deviation
of plus minus 20 minutes
so this was really really good because
it was a really fast
reliable and robust method to be
able to measure the self-healing of
ourselves
and in a rapid way
i'm very consistent which was great to
see
then the next next
step that we took was to
see if we could use this platform when
we had none other than target cells
and this could be a little bit
counter-intuitive
because in order for this assay to be
able to work
we need to attach the cells to the
bottom of the plate so in order to try
to achieve this
uh we use two different antibodies
antibody a
and antibody beam antibodies on the left
hand side and antibody biggest on the
right hand side
and to test this we play the difference
in intensities
and we use different amount of
antibodies and as you can see from
from the two plots antibody b was much
better because we managed to obtain
a higher cell index when we pre-coded
the wealth with this antibody
excuse me so once we have determined the
specific antibody concentration the next
step was to try to
identify what was the optimal seed
intensity
so for that again we coated the wells
uh with a specific amount of antibody
and then we tested different set
intensities
and as you can see um all the
seed densities that were higher um
to the one that is highlighted on the
square
had the same cell index levels uh
so therefore that indicated that we were
reaching saturation levels
with that specific cell concentration
and is the one that we decided to use
for our fat experiments
so we have determined the optimal
activity concentration
and we have also determined the optimal
seed intensity
so once those two parameters were set we
were ready to perform
the kirin assay and in this case the
assay outline was a little bit different
uh what we had to do was to incubate
these nonadherent target cells
with a specific antigen of interest for
two hours
before plating then the target cells are
plated
and allowed to attach for four hours
um and as you can see there is an
initial attachment
and then during those two to four hours
the cells reached the plateau and this
is the point that we were looking to be
able to
affect ourselves and then we had a
different affected to target cell ratios
so
one to one in blue to two one in purple
and five to one in green and
green so as you can see the higher the
affected target ratios
the more pronounced is the killing
effect
and we were quite interested actually in
seeing
how this impedance-based platform
performed compared to other technologies
such as flow cytometry
or a quantitative image analysis
so in order to be able to compare the
different technologies
we designed the following experiment so
we have
our engineer effector cells and then we
have our target cells in four different
conditions
the first condition is the cells that
were incubated
in the presence of our specific antigen
of interest
and then we have three negative controls
so that is the target cells alone
and then the target cells are proposed
with non-specific
two different non-specific peptides and
that is represented in the green and in
the blue color
um after the cells were paused
we co-culture them on the impedance
plate in a five to one effect of the
target ratio
and as you can see in the graph we only
observe
um a killing effect on the cells that
were only
posed with the specific peptide
and from this graph we could determine
that
after eight hours more or less there was
a clear difference
between the positive and the negative
controls and we decided to take that
specific time point
for our flow cytometry comparative
comparative analysis
so in order to be able to perform flow
cytometry and this thing with the two
different populations
we have to pre-label one of them so in
this case we pre-label the
effect itself effector cells with a
fluorescent compound
after the cells were labeled then we put
in culture
the target and the affective cells and
after eight hours
we evaluated the levels of apoptotic
cells
using an xm5 and 780
and then monitor the the proportion of
live cells
and as you can see in this chart on the
right hand side
we have in blue the data from the
impedance platform
and in orange the data that we obtained
from source cytometry
and they gave very comparable results
where we only
see a clear reduction in the viability
of the cells
when we look at the cells that were
false only with a specific peptide
not in not in any of the other
conditions
and we did a similar experiment using
quantitative analysis
for that we have to label the cells the
target cells
with a green fluorescent compound the
effector cells were labeled in blue
and the cells will appear later on
during the killing in red
and as you can see on the right hand
side
the results of this
quantitative image analysis showed very
comparable results to the graphs that we
have shown in the previous slide
with the experience data
so to summarize this part we have shown
that
we can show and measure the
potency of a tcr immunotherapy product
using the impedance based platform
and we have also shown two different
methods to monitor the t cells extorting
city
either using ambient cells and
non-abundant cells
and discuss different parameters that
needs to be optimized
during this process and also we have
shown
that the assay that correlates with flow
cytometry
and image analysis however the impedance
offers some benefits that is label free
and also provide kinetic information of
this algorithm
for this last part of the presentation i
wanted to use this example where
we supported one of our collaborators
trying to
progress the product from early research
stages
into the clinic and for that
we used a american antigen receptor
diesel product and the aim of
this part of the work was to try to
evaluate the potency
using the impedance platform
a chimeric cathedral receptor
or carti cells work in a slightly
different way
compared to the tcr ones so in this case
the
chimeric antigen receptor has four
different
functional domains we have the target
binding domain that is a cellular
then we have a hinge domain that is a
transmembrane domain
and we have two intercellular domains
the question monetary one
and the essential for the activation so
once the target binding domain
binds to the target antigen that will
trigger
the cytolytic activity of the t cell a
cyto can release
a cell proliferation and i am sure that
most of you are aware that there are
currently two
of the approved
medicinal products based on car t-cells
to tackle
a visceral malignancies
so uh however if we want to target
um solid tumors we have different
challenges that we need to face
one of them is access to the tumor side
another challenge is the lack of
appropriate target antigens
we need to find markers that are only
expressed on the cancer cells
and not any health tissues because if
those were also expressing healthy
tissues
the car t cells will also damage them
and another aspect is to consider the
immunosuppressive tumor microenvironment
so we thought that a potential
therapeutic approach
could be to try to target the tumor
musculature
so during tumor formation and tumor
development that humerogenic cells
are able to secrete iodine factors
that will promote the formation of new
new vessels
those new vessels will supply nutrient
nutrients from from the blood and they
could also
be a way of a metastatic spread
so if we were able to target this new
vasculature
we will um stop the supply from
nutrients
to the tumor and that will definitely
slow
the growth and potentially be able to to
reduce the size of the
of the tumor or maybe meant to eliminate
it and we will be able to
try to trying to prevent the metastatic
spread
of the those humanogenic cells
so our collaborators identified
that click 14a could be a potential
tumor endothelial marker
because as you can see on this slide it
is only expressed in the vasculature
of tumor tissues that we have on the
hand side of the
panel but not in their healthy
counterparts on the right hand side of
the panel
so basically we have on the top pressed
carcinoma samples in the middle
liver carcinoma and on the bottom panel
bladder carcinoma and you can see
colocalization
and of clay 14a and
endothelial marker and however we are
not able to detect kleck-fortinate on
their healthy counterparts
in any of the tissues that we that they
they evaluated
then our collaborators entering um
perform some in vivo studies in this
case they use
a rib tactical mouse model so these
animals develop the tumor in the
pancreas
and they use either moxed transduced
cells
or cells albertans used with the
americans again
receptor and as you can see in those
animals that were infused
with the with the cardi cells there was
a reduction in the expression levels
of 2014 in the musculature
and they quantified these images and
they saw a significant
reduction in the vessel area in those
animals that received
the cardi cells there was also a
significant reduction in the expression
levels
of collect for dna in the vasculature of
those animals that received
the cardi cells and there was an
increase in the apoptotic marker caspase
3 which is a marker of cell death
in the vasculature of those animals that
receive the car t cells
in addition to this they also measured
the tumor size
and they found a significant reduction
when comparing
the tumor volume of the animals that
were
injected with the mock cells compared to
the ones that received
the cardi cells so there was a reduction
of around 50
in tumor volume which was really
promising
however our challenge here was to try
to change a little bit
the whole process so we wanted to try to
develop
a closed system where we could
try to reduce the time of manufacturing
and also the way of generating these car
key cells
so if you remember from from the first
slides we discussed that this is a
lengthy process that normally takes
around
10 to 12 days and it requires the use
of viral vectors
excuse me so we wanted to take a
different approach
and see if we could reduce the overall
manufacturing time uh avoid the use of
viral vectors
and and then by these two different
strategies try to reduce the costs
of of producing this material and also
um
take a different approach by not having
a
stable expression of the car but just
like a trans
transiting expression and we did that by
electroporating an mrna
instead so we use the
in this instrument the clean max prodigy
where we can start with the initial
material that we can perform the cd4 and
cd8
isolation we can keep the cells in
culture
if we need we cannot in addition to
perform our direct operation to
to insert the mrna into the cells
and then finalize the product with
harvesting the
material we tested two different methods
so activating the cells as the typical
manufacturing process that we discussed
at the beginning of the presentation
and using non-activated cells and this
was the approach that could
potentially shorten the the whole
process
and as you can see we managed to get
very
good viability in both cases and very
good transfection efficiency
so it was slightly higher in the
activated cells
but it was not significantly different
compared to the non-activated material
but for the purposes of optimizing the
impedance assay we used transient cells
so
these were generated with a viral vector
and they were steadily expressing the
climatic antigen
receptor so as you can see on this graph
we used a very low effective to target
ratios so in this case it was single
five to one
and one to one and even though they were
a very small effector ratios we managed
to observe a hidden effect
within three hours so on the right hand
side you can see
the quantification of the results
evaluating the killing time safety
on three different assays and they were
very
very consistent and very reproducible
and as you can see within four hours we
managed to
to reach um the killing 1050 value
uh but what happened to those cells that
we generated with the
messenger rna so in this graph we have a
summary
of the experiment that we perform in
which we have
transduced cells which are our controls
so these cells
should be inducing a high hearing effect
constantly over time and that is what
happens as you can see on the purple
line
over nine days a
time period the normalized cell index
was
a constantly very low which is a sign of
a
high potency of the product and if you
look at the
green line which is the transfect cells
with the messenger rna
so on day zero they have the same
killing potential
as the transduced cells however over
time
they start to lose this potency or this
ability to
kill because of course the messenger rna
gets degraded
and therefore the expression of the
chemical antigen receptor protein will
be degraded
um with a with the time
a and another way that we
measure the potency of those transfected
cells
was by measuring cytokine release in
this case the
luminex platform where we could measure
the expression levels of interferon
gamma
and ground side b and as you can see it
was a dramatic
increased expression of these two
cytokines
when the cells were transfected with the
with the messenger
rna so this was another additional way
to prove the potency
of the cells that we manufacture
using this new strategy
so to summarize the the whole
presentation we have shown that
we can measure the potency of either
tcr-based therapies or cultist-based
therapies
in a reliably and robust way using the
impedance
spectroscopy we have shown the
specificity of the assay independently
of
therapy use and in addition again the
impedance assay is
label-free and provides dynamic or
kinetic data of the cell healing
not only during the assay but also as we
have seen in the previous slide
over a different period of time and the
ascii provides a fast
and high throughput alternative to
current methodologies that can
eventually help us to try to reduce
the time between equality control
release
and administration into to the patient
i would like to of course take this
opportunity to thank all the people that
were involved in these
different aspects of this work either
performing the
individual experiments or in
process development trying to generate
either the transducers or the
electroporated cells
members of the team for critical
discussion and ideas
and of course i would like to take this
opportunity to thank you
and i hope that you found this webinar
interesting and that you can take some
ideas to apply to your own
research if you have any questions
please i would like to
to have the opportunity to answer them
and i will try
my best to do so thank you so much again
thank you very much juan miguel for that
excellent
presentation uh we will now
start the question and answer portion
of the webinar if you have any questions
you'd like to ask please submit it
we'll be able to get to a couple of
questions before the end of the hour
however even if we don't make make it to
your questions
we'll be forwarding all of them on to
our speaker
and the agilent team to follow up with
you
so let's get started with some of the
questions
to uh juan miguel so
so one you talked about basically coding
with
fibronectin is that required
all the time in this assay or maybe
perhaps for
only certain cell types
it's only for certain cell types so some
of them we didn't have to use
fibronectin
but for as you can as you saw in some of
these slides
uh fibronectin really helped uh to
improve the attachments and the
cell intake signal uh for some of our
cell lines but it's not required at all
times so it's an optional step that you
can
perform on your experiments
great thank you thank you for that and
this real-time cell analysis as a
obviously
you mentioned that you know you would
have to add the
effectors and allow the experiment to
proceed
is there an optimal time point
or time duration let's say uh for which
the this potency assay needs to be
conducted or does that really depend on
the
type of a factor one is uh looking at
is yeah basically you answer the
question is more dependent on the
on your effector cells uh obviously the
duration time
um is going to be affected by your
transaction efficiency uh and also yeah
the total amount of cytotoxic t cells
that you have
in your product with some of these
linearity studies that we perform we try
to show that
you will have a faster killing ratio if
you have an increased number of
cytotoxic
t cells
okay great thank you um
you you spoke about um two
uh types of parameters uh when you were
doing your
calculation one was the kt50
value and the other one was cell index
at a given time
do you have any preference for one or
the other or do you think
both of those are important or does one
each
one have a certain unique value
my personal preference would be the
killing time 50
because it is a more consistent
parameter
so it will be specific
just to measure when you reduce these
normalization normalized settings from
one to zero five
uh that will give you a specific value
all the time whereas the
if you choose to determine a cell index
or the specific time point
is more variable and it's just depending
on the operator but
it's great because the assets are
flexible and then
depending on your needs you can choose
what parameters you should
should suit your needs better sorry
great thank you uh thank you for that
in in in in your discussion um uh
one of the questions that we got is you
talked about
like the residuals as part of the
linear regression analysis can you uh
please expand on that
uh so it was one of the parameters that
we evaluated to basically
see if the linear regression model
fitted our data points so when we
evaluated the
linearity of the number of cells that we
played it onto the impedance and see we
have a direct correlation between the
number of cells at the same index
they followed a linear regression
because the
residual plots show like scatter points
uh
however when we evaluate the linearity
on the cytotoxic potential of the t
cells
uh it was not on the slice but we also
did the receivable plots
and in that case when we did linear
regression the residual plots show the
specific pattern
and that means that it's not a model
that is going to fit your data points
and when i just need a exponential
regression
then the residual plot was scattered
suggesting that our model fitted better
an exponential regression for that
correlation
okay well uh with that we are
very close to reaching the top of the
hour
um even though we have some addition for
you but we'll make sure that we will
send that
uh to you one and uh thank you again
uh for sharing your work with us today
and thanks
to our audience uh for your questions
and
also for your participation thank you
very much one
thank you very much bye